Mike Solana is the editor-in-chief of
pirate wires an independent Media
company that continues to question the
public narrative and talk about all of
the topics that you'll care about he
also is an entrepreneur in Residence at
Founders fun and he is one of the best
independent critical thinkers that I
know this conversation covers all of the
insanity of the last couple of years and
tries to seek out where there is truth
and fact compared to all of the
conspiracy theories and the fiction that
you may read in mainstream headlines
here is my conversation with Mike Solana
sanity and Truth in an insane world
Where Do We Begin I don't know
what are you talking about today I'm
like no idea there are lots of cover
let's start with the insane World
um it feels like and I'm going to speak
for the audience that
we all went to sleep in 2019. and it was
kind of crazy
we all had the internet but when we woke
up in 2020
everything got insane
there was the politics there was the
economy the FED uh there was the public
health I mean you just go down the line
and it's literally the mean clown world
yeah became popular for a reason how do
you evaluate like what happened and like
how did we get deeper and deeper into
this insane world
I think you're right I think that it is
it was something it was like 2020 I
wouldn't say that things became
extremely clownish I would say that that
was the year that it all
became impossible to ignore it was like
suddenly like there were a lot of things
that were kind of had gone off of the
Rails but in the middle of a pandemic
suddenly you needed people to be serious
and it was like at that moment that the
complete lack of seriousness became a
disaster
um and I and that's what I like if you
think it back like sort of the height of
uh maybe the sort of identity politics
and stuff like that it was in 2020 in my
opinion right before 2020 I was saying
it was over it was 2017. at the very
height when like Aziz Ansari was being
you know murdered for a bad date and
things like this I was like it could
never get worse than that and then 2020
happened and rioting was legalized and
you were like uh wow it's like there's
like no bottom here but I think actually
what was happening was like
that was uh it was like extinct it was
like Behavior Extinction it was like to
get the same
level of of uh of uh of attention I
think for Behavior people had to go and
get a little more extreme and plus it
was a pandemic and people were losing
their minds but yeah for sure that was
the year that everything kind of so it's
interesting let's take the legalization
of riots
um which again most people won't even
talk about at this point
um
there's the discourse and then there's
the like
actions in your local community so I was
living in New York while some of this
was going on and there was three
different events all within like a two
or three uh week
um uh timeline
there was one video that went viral and
I think it was like Washington Square
Park or maybe down the flat iron or
something we're literally the police
were having a fist fight with citizens
like there was a bunch of Chaos in the
in the one angle of the video was like
two guys squared up once a cop and one's
a citizen and they're like punching each
other like like a backyard School fight
or something yeah but I remember I mean
there was we've again like this stuff
has been coming for a while I forget now
even what the protest was but a while
back there was it was some kind of a
quality protest I believe maybe maybe it
was 2020. I have to go back and look but
there was a girl if you were to just
Google like Molotov cocktail girl this
will come up and I remember there's like
this crazy Riot and this reporter I mean
usually the media is like doing all
sorts of crazy [__] but in this case I
cannot blame them they were just like
hey so what's going on here the reporter
said to this person in front of like
absolute chaos everywhere this girl's
holding a Molotov cocktail and and she's
just like blightly sort of like
explaining what's going on and the
reported narrative she's like and then
she just she just tossed it into a cop
car and landed on fire so then she gets
that that girl actually got arrested
um and then the framing was like I mean
come on like mistakes were made right
cocktail at a cop car cast the first
stone and it's like that's I mean that's
really some that's some crazy [__] in
the moment in 2020 that's when I started
writing for pirate wires so it was like
I think that was the most depressed I
ever was that June of 2020 when all of
the crazy behavior from the preceding
years
kind of Amplified and in the context of
this you know really scary at the time
it was scary virus that we didn't know
much about
so I started writing just to like kind
of make sense of the world for myself uh
and then it connected with people and
I've been doing it since so before we
get into pirate wire some of the things
you guys have covered
um you work at a place where uh
Founder's fun previously at Founders
well I'm still there
you are an entrepreneur in Residence yes
right which uh is like the best position
to be in because that means that you
definitely can work on whatever you want
I guess I mean I always could and now
it's like official all right uh is known
for independent thinking right uh and
now you're writing
and when you started to write one you're
very articulate you have a very kind of
uh memorable way of writing right
um but you're willing to take on topics
that most people just won't touch or if
they do write about it it is from what I
would consider the like consensus view
so you'll see a New York Times article
and they'll write something and you're
like oh is that like what everyone
believes and then I'll get an email from
you on your sub stack and I'm like oh no
that's not what everyone believes I'm
like right you actually took it head on
where does that come from so
I believe that
I think the average person doesn't think
much about
what's going on at all and I think
they're kind of looking around for for
cues on what they're allowed to say and
things like this and I understand that
impulse because it's scary like there
are real consequences to some kind of
saying the wrong thing and especially
over the last few years I mean that's
the whole game is to terrify people into
not not thinking about the world you
know you just assume that your thoughts
are incorrect and things like this my
assumption is that if I just make my
case plainly
um and not in a mean way unless someone
really deserves it which occasionally
happens but but not be mean if you could
if you could not be if you could just if
you could just make the case uh in the
most obvious way I think the average
person would see the reason in it and
and they'll see that you're at least not
trying to cause
like trouble you're you're really just
expressing uh uh what I think are mostly
for the most part uh they're not all
common sense but when it comes to like
things like crime and things like this
crime homelessness drugs those tend to
be more common sense positions and then
when it comes to technology and Analysis
and things like that that's maybe a
little more complicated but only because
you're not steeped in it which is the
other thing like I like to bring people
I happen to know a lot about what's
going on in Tech just because I'm
fortunate enough to sit with people who
are really great at this stuff and so I
like to kind of like it like share that
with people with with my audience
pirate wires the name uh was very
intentional explain what is a pirate
liar why did you call it
man I mean the first thing is like it's
just a Vibe it just makes me happy like
it just came to me one day I was like
that's cool I'm gonna call it that
um but I mean a pirate wire is like it's
like Pirate Radio is what I think about
I think about the Forbidden things that
you're not allowed to say and uh and I
kind of just also think about I mean we
all live online now and that's it's like
this clownish cartoon reality
um and I imagine it almost as like the
Open Seas and there are these people who
are bringing a lot to it there are
people who are causing damage out there
there are fights and Wars there's giant
sea monsters and we're just like not a
part of the main Nations where like this
little pirate ship or this little now
pirate Fleet kind of off to the side
maybe building our own little pirate
nation in a kind of Hidden Cove
um and that's just how I think about it
I try and have fun online uh and and
laugh at the really crazy stuff because
that's also a Gateway I feel like that's
how people connect with each other you
were the first person to say this to me
um you said that you bought a bunch of
encyclopedias if I remember correctly oh
yeah and you were reading them and I was
like what a [__] nerd
in my head but I was like why are you
doing that which analog the connection
between my brain and my mouth like it
translated into why would you do that
and then you explained
well maybe they're going to change
what's in the encyclopedia yeah and I
was like that's a crazy thought fast
forward two years not such a crazy
thought this is the crazy I think this
is probably the craziest thing about our
information landscape is that it's
totally malleable and I mean the sort of
dream of the internet when I was a kid
uh was like this was going to be free
unlimited information all of the
information that exists in the world was
going to now be available to everybody
and so you have this idea of what
information meant back then like even a
couple decades ago information you were
imagining like like the official record
now everyone would have it the official
information like like the sort of
scientific studies and things like that
all of that would be available what we
did not see coming was the fact that
everything changes so obviously
Wikipedia is the is an easy example but
the dictionary right like like
definitions in the dictionary change
like actual articles that used to exist
have been altered in real time they're
not even all you know they're not even
given notation on social media things
are said and then deleted costs
instantly the Wayback machine you can
just have anything wiped any any sort of
history and so the idea of an
encyclopedia which Britannica I don't
think has I think their last
encyclopedia might have been in the late
2000 it might have been like 2008 or
you'd have to double I'm not sure the
date but but it's it's at least 10 years
old like the the last uh edition of the
Encyclopedia Britannica
um
it suddenly had value that I 20 years
ago thought was laughable it's like who
care like analog like paper wow are you
living in the Primitive times I could
never think of the utility of that of a
hard record
um and that's the weird thing that I'm
grappling with I think day to day is
like my love of Technology I've been a
sort of progressive like techno utopian
guy for a lot of my formative years with
the consequences of that that we're
seeing increasingly all around us um and
the malleability of or the malleable
nature of information is one of those
things where like
in a world where everything's changing
when you can't when you there's no
record of of what was said five seconds
ago I remember Amy Comey uh Barrett
saying uh she used the word the phrase
sexual preference in her hearing before
she became a Justice and immediately
everyone was like oh that's you know
really offensive just look at the
dictionary the dictionary that day
changed the definition of sexual
preference and and that became a part of
the story and it's like
definitely just just so like people
understand like when he says change the
definition like literally online they
went and they changed the definition
that day in real time in response to a
Huffington Post article that was going
viral calling her you know a bigot and
whatnot and sexual preference is like I
mean I'm gay I know gay people who have
used that phrase like not recently it's
kind of dated but is it is it bigoted uh
no that's not bigoted to me that's not
it's like not like dropping an F-bomb
it's not the same thing and that is how
it was it was reframed now that one
topic doesn't really matter so much as
the sort of high level fact of our
reality which is that we have no record
that we can go back to and say this is
the truth this is the thing that we all
said we agreed on because that doesn't
exist anymore
um and so I think like a high level
problem we all have now is like
given that that's the reality of our
life how do you make sense of what's
going on and so how do you balance out
with like let's take uh the lab leak
which uh you and I have had plenty of uh
nice conversations about
um 2020 I think it was Zero Hedge was
the first one I saw that said it they
were deleted Within
minutes you know hours whatever it was
uh which had the opposite effect of not
like oh wow look at those morons
actually it was like
maybe that's true yeah right of like why
would they not want us to read that
um and so from there to eventually I
remember
um somebody put together a bunch of like
pseudonymous people put together uh like
a Google drive or like a like a Google
doc that was circulating around for a
while and they had I mean incredibly
detailed research it was all cited like
it was very well done where I would say
like a professional did it or a group of
professionals but they weren't willing
to put their name on it right and so
that was circulating around on Twitter
for a while uh and then I remember the
first politician who said it on national
television and they were yelling and
screaming and saying you know uh
conspiracy theories and like you know
all that kind of stuff to now we have
reports like the department of energy
which I'm not sure why they're looking
into it because they run a bunch of labs
got it so they run all of our National
Labs and a bunch of international Labs
these organizations now that previously
were like there's no way that this is
true this is CR you know conspiracy uh
Theory stuff they're like oh we have low
level confidence some of them have you
know medium level confidence whatever
like that is
the truth right
has the truth evolved throughout that
time or is it that now it's just okay to
talk about certain things that maybe
weren't off you know off the table
before like how do you think about that
situation as a good example the lab leak
is
it's a lot like Hunter Biden's laptop
right it's like this issue that is just
it is like in more than one way it goes
out of stone for the information
landscape you look at it and you're like
oh that's how everything works got it
um with with the with with the lab leak
I don't first of all my confidence that
that the virus leak from a lab is not
you know 90 I'm probably like 60. I
think like I'm like 60 it came from a
lab 40 zoonotic like I don't it's like
it seems likely and yet there's evidence
kind of in arguments in both directions
what bothered me about the lab leak was
that we couldn't talk about it
um and we couldn't ask those questions
and we weren't even allowed I mean in
the early days there wasn't an
investigation happening it was like the
times was asking I linked back to uh uh
I don't know if it was the times but I
the other day I was looking back at my
own commentary on this stuff and I came
across a Wikipedia article at the time
that linked to uh in in evidence that
the lab leak theory was complete
Conspiracy Theory with no validity
whatsoever there were three broken links
and the fourth went to a who it was like
a World Health Organization slash uh
like China thing where basically like
Chinese like like the CCP agents were
like hey those are like Chinese
officials were like it didn't happen and
and that was their evidence and it's
like okay that's crazy like what was
happening back then was just we weren't
even asking the question
um because we weren't allowed to and
there are a lot of reasons that make
sense it's like maybe people wanted to
work with China at the time you don't
want to alienate them like they know a
lot about the virus potentially like I
understand in the same way that fauci
lied about masks in the first time he
lied about masks when it was like oh no
you don't want masks because he wanted
to make sure there were enough masks for
all the doctors and things like that
which he's come out and said he's
apologized for it and well I knew that
even then that was obvious even then it
was like obviously that's what they're
trying to do but the problem with that
is it destroys and this is a separate
subject but like the problem with
something like that is it completely
destroys our trust in these people who
we need to trust in the moment in in the
middle of a of a crisis and so it's like
with a lot of these things with the lab
leak thing and with the hunter Biden
thing back in the day like I can I can
understand the
I can understand why someone would lie
they think for our own good however
they shouldn't have that much power for
ab for these reasons because they're
often wrong and on things like this it's
like you're wrong about our public
health or something like that
um it can be really dangerous what I
always appreciate about you is uh you
don't have super strong belief on the
lab League or on uh even like the faucy
situation like you're able to unpack oh
I see from their seat why they would do
that or I see why uh the incentive pulls
them towards that action how do you look
at a situation like let's just say
something happens tomorrow
how do you go through that process is it
just like you sit there like oh if I was
in their seat these would be the options
or like what is that process like so
that people can help as people in the
audience learn about situations in the
future what would be your advice or kind
of your like very practical guide of
like here's how to think through
something I think that you have to just
be comfortable with your own curiosity
and like accept the idea that you are
allowed to have an opinion and you are
allowed to ask questions the the lab
leak was like we're talking about a
virus that was supposed to that perhaps
has emerged completely randomly like
down the street from a coronavirus
Factory that's insane like you should be
able to ask questions like hey what's
going on over at the place where they're
studying rare back coronaviruses like
down the block that is like that's not a
crazy question to ask and the fact that
we were framed like these crazy people
is insane and so you have to just be
like okay well screw all of them like
what makes what am I curious about what
doesn't add up to me and then you just
ask those questions
um the danger is that you you suddenly
start believing everything that the
other people who are asking similar
questions are are saying they believe
because online I don't even know what
people believe a lot of people say [__]
and they don't even believe it it's just
identity based posturing or they want
attention and it's just a really
complicated environment so
there is the fear of just believing the
consensus right and I read ex mainstream
outlet they said this that's my belief
uh and so you want to avoid that but you
also don't want to then become the
conspiracy theorist like an actual
conspiracy theorist who's like oh my God
I think that there's an alien who like
brought this diamond down from the sky I
mean like let's not let's not say never
so how do you I guess like on the other
side you know I almost think of it like
bumpers right you want to be able to ask
questions and do all this stuff but like
look you can go on a website online and
pick your like super novel topic
and you start reading stuff and like you
very quickly could become convinced of
something that like if you're able to
take a step back and like wait a minute
this is insane like there's no way that
you know a b and c all add up how do you
prevent like over rotating to what would
be the conspiracy side as well
well first of all some conspiracies
exist and so it's like to be a
conspiracy theorist like they're like
there have been conspiracies
um
so you don't want to close yourself off
to the topic generally speaking I mean
the UFO thing will be a good example
right like this conspiracy has
completely flipped there for my entire
life up until 2017 the conspiracy was
that uh the government was hiding
evidence if UFOs now the government's
like yo we've got a lot of evidence of
UFOs here's videos and so the conspiracy
theorist just just happened and the last
one the conspiracy theorists were like
the government is lying about UFOs to
distract you from either the chemical
fires in Ohio or like they want you to
go to war with China or like whatever it
is so there's like a new conspiracy
theory and so or several
um and I guess it's like again it's the
Curiosity and you have to distrust
yourself uh to just
two things one follow your own curiosity
and then maybe the other thing is like
anytime a story is is too good and this
happens to me on Twitter all the time
there are people who are like
there's like some story there's some
some news thing that seems like just too
perfectly in sync with all of my priors
like I I want to roast it I want to dunk
on it I want to be like look what the
world is doing uh you just gotta go and
actually read the article and uh and
then you have to try and find some other
counter sources like what are people who
are mad about this thing I do this all
the time I read the New York Times a lot
um I think I am sort of naturally like a
little bit
opposite them ideologically not like
very far but um I think it's it's a
healthy I feel to be reading people who
uh I don't say don't agree with me but
but uh challenge me in a way are you
looking for Content when you do that
like I almost think of it as a comedian
a comedian goes lives their life and
they're like they're looking for oh look
I saw the situation that's going to be a
good joke they go back and they kind of
come up with the the set are you going
to the websites and like I need [__] to
write about and so like that one look at
these idiots I've never not known to
write about I've got like a lot of
things I want to talk about uh but
that's probably why because I have I'm
like compulsively like reading up on
what's going on I find it just fun and
exciting
um and I consider that sort of my job
now is to is to like follow this stuff
and uh and provide my perspective that I
hope can be useful to some people you've
been pulled into
um some very interesting uh debates most
notably you were uh maybe briefly or
wrongfully uh labeled as a billionaire
media Tycoon uh by a politician
literally uh Lorena Gonzalez can you
explain the situation
sorry about that I'm grateful for for
what she gave me it was really awesome
so explain what she uh attacked you
about and then talk a little bit about
as a private citizen yes you're in the
tech industry but you're a private
citizen like do they see it as a threat
is that why now the playing field has
been leveled on Twitter what is the
threat a politician going after a
private citizen on Twitter or vice versa
like how do you think about you know
there used to be this very big gap right
and like you couldn't talk to your
politician you could like write a letter
and hope they got it you may be able to
call and like talk to someone on their
team maybe you went to an event they
were like on stage but you couldn't like
be sitting on the toilet and like firing
off at a politician and they're
responding back yeah you could never I I
think it's not just them either it's
it's it's politicians it's public health
officials it's the media um they're
these are all the people who are used to
getting Relentless criticism were people
who worked in the Private Industry
um so journalists often say that that
CEOs and things like this are thin skin
tech people are thin-skinned I think
that actually there's some truth that
like no one likes to have negative
things written about them in the press
and everybody when someone when
something negative is written about them
that your first reaction is like well
they're lying kind of because they they
kind of are like if someone really hates
you they're they're not lying they're
like framing things in a way that make
you seem really bad uh and so that's
what you're sort of naturally reacting
to and that's I think understandable but
still public companies are more they're
used to this in a way I guess
the government has been as well well the
Republican anyone who is Republican in
government is used to criticism
um I think there's something much more
intimate about this this like this mass
of people who are are very close to you
and like you said it's like it's just
some guy in his toilet like talking to
one of the most powerful senators in the
country and they sometimes respond
because they feel like they have to
because everybody's looking
um it's very threatening to to power in
general Lorena was almost a good sport
about it
um this is the woman who told Elon uh
[__] you and then he was like okay cool
I'm out and you just like left of the
state
um with a few billion dollars in taxes
so yeah she we got in a thing and she
she was like you know billionaires like
you could never understand
um and that just became a part of my
internet like
bodysuit I was just like added I just
like all these like strange titles that
I collect but I think the anger
generally from people like that is this
it's like the sense of of uh of how dare
you and maybe fear because they're not
wrong that
um you do need certain people to be just
in charge and like this feels this does
feel this much chaos uh does feel sort
of
unstable sometimes a lot of uh I think
what you and I get out of uh the
internet and enjoy talking about is kind
of like look how crazy this is this is
insane what are you people doing
Etc what's going right what are the
positives like when you wake up in the
morning where do you look and you're
like man this is actually like really
energizing and puts me in the mood to go
and like take the hill because I feel
like we're uh we're actually making
progress somewhere oh I think there's a
lot uh more sort of every day I think
that in the first place
I don't know what to call it some people
call it wokeness some people call it
like uh like identitarianism or whatever
that thing was that made it impossible
for us to speak
um that sort of affected every single
aspect of Our Lives over the last few
years where uh we were reduced to our
gender and our sex and things like this
our race
um
I think that's kind of over like I think
or at least it's Monopoly on culture is
over like you're very much now allowed
to criticize these things and you can
tell that by the fact that there's an
entire sort of like cottage industry
online that exists to make fun of it and
to and to attack it and to criticize it
there are successful activists now I
would say on the other side of it who
are making a lot of progress in places
like Florida
um and progress you know their version
of of that which is to say but like that
that was impossible a few years ago
there's much more I would say balance
um
I think that's great I think that uh in
the context of
I write a lot about local politics I
think it's this weirdly important thing
that nobody cares about you know it's
not it's not sexy
um it doesn't pay well and yet you know
the president doesn't really matter in
your day-to-day life we realized under
covid the thing that mattered were like
the five Psychopaths on your board of
education you know like they had all the
power and so like people have to have to
care about that kind of stuff and what
I've noticed especially in San Francisco
I mean I live in Miami but I spent uh I
spend a good enough amount of time now
in San Francisco to kind of be aware of
what's going on and all my friends still
live there
um
foreign
gets a lot of [__] for being the
craziest city in the country it's not
I've been all over the country every
city is bad like they're all they all
have the same problems they all have a
drug problem they all have a homeless
problem they all have those crazy people
on the board of education all of them
there's like not an exception to that in
the big cities the difference is people
in San Francisco were talking about it
and getting attention for it and now
what you're seeing are people in a lot
of these cities who are really pushing
back we've seen evidence of that across
the board there are people who want just
basic very very basic things like they
want the school the schools are now open
but like that they're like the schools
need to be open and the schools need to
be run by sane people and
um things like I don't know fentanyl
dealing should be illegal is you should
not be allowed to do that uh and I think
those people are kind of coming back in
charge so there's there's like a rough
sort of Common Sense Resurgence that I'm
excited about and then there's Tech
stuff too but we could talk about that
later so one of the interesting things
about crime San Francisco I think being
a example
um is that the people who are trying to
address the crime they're experimenting
they may not call it experimenting but
they will look at things and they will
say well maybe we shouldn't be so
directly confrontational we should do
more of like a rehabilitation uh maybe
if we kind of give them a sector of the
city and let them do crazy stuff over
there they won't do it elsewhere
um the like generalizations of the San
Francisco is like no they're just going
to run rampant or like literally they
just walk in CVS and it's basically like
they walked into their personal Pantry
at their house right just grab whatever
they want like how do you balance what I
think the tech industry would agree is
like the ability to question things the
ability to test things you know the
ability to try to iterate towards a
solution
but also you're doing it with Public
Safety you're doing it with like a city
how do like what is the solution or like
if you were the mayor of San Francisco
what would you be doing there to try to
address like crime or homelessness but
maybe taking the approach of like hey I
don't have like a one-size-fits-all
solution on day one I gotta kind of
figure it out
uh I think that so there are a couple
questions there I think the one that's
I'll start with maybe is just yeah how
do you balance this desire for like shut
it down we need to clean the streets and
also like you need to experiment to make
things better uh I love that question I
would say that we have experimented like
like we've done it like we ran we ran
the experiment it's been Decades of this
[__] it's time to shut it down like the
like the open air drug markets not
working uh like the sort of legalized
fentanyl dealing it's like not a good
thing uh we could just toss those uh and
then be maybe a little more open to I
think once we get to some sort of basic
common like
in San Francisco famously there was this
problem of like people were going people
were [__] on the street like
everywhere like human [__] everywhere
you looked like that's literally you
would walk down the street and people
would joke don't step in the shed and it
was it was from people not dogs and it's
like that's that is you can't
function in a society like that like
that's like that we're breaking down in
a pretty serious way at that point it's
like there has to be a ground floor and
at that ground floor when people feel
safe when uh there's not you know I mean
there's like a mass murder happening
with fentanyl in San Francisco right now
I know for a fact and I think all the
cities are pretty bad with this stuff
but SF is where I just I know I happen
to know the most about it
um
once you clean that kind of stuff up you
should be running experiments and I
think probably where you start is not at
the scale of you know a million person
City but like maybe a town and like
maybe we start there one also probably
safety is a very different place to
experiment than uh let's come up with a
better parking system yeah right I don't
want to experiment with new drugs on my
body right like let um happy for other
people to do the experimentation there
and then I'll see you in a few years
yeah what what is uh one or two topics
that you have not written about either
because you're scared to write about
them or you feel like uh it needs enough
Nuance in conversation versus in writing
oh man that topic whatever you just were
thinking we should talk about well I
think there are a couple I I mean I
think the obvious one is I will say the
one that I messed up on okay which was I
really wanted to talk about
I was a I was early I loved Bitcoin I
was really to it I was very
ideologically aligned with it at the
time I still sort of am uh I still
mostly am
um but I was at my most ideal uh
ideologically along with Bitcoin
um
maybe around 2013 I think I got into it
and I'd known about it for a while and
I'd been thinking about it but like it
was 2013 when I got in uh I would say
things got like
pretty ridiculous towards the end you
know there were some great things
happening and there were some crazy
things happening and I wish that I had I
had so many friends who were working on
this stuff
and I didn't I just didn't want to I
just didn't want to get involved I felt
like there are other people talking
about it I don't need to talk about it
um but now I really regret it and so
because you wanted to bring up the crazy
stuff and like kind of critique it I
think that there were some crazy things
that needed
I mean there were clearly some crazy
things that needed to be critiqued and
so I wish that I would have been a part
of that because I knew I had that
impulse and I didn't and I silenced
myself not for fear of and this is the
maybe the really the most dangerous one
it was not for fear of what a bunch of
[__] on the internet were going to
say about me it was like for fear of
what my friends would think about me and
I didn't want to hurt anybody's feelings
who I cared about and that's a problem
and so I really regret that I should
have spoken up I had these feelings I
never was like pumping crazy [__] I was
never like uh but I should have
expressed thoughtful sort of concern at
the time I'm trying to sort of bring
that now to how I talk about AI
um which is a whole other topic I will
say the other thing the thing that I
have not talked about uh which is
probably the thing that no one talks
about which is race and I I that one is
a complicated I'm like I'm like do I
need to talk like lots of people are
talking about it uh I don't know how to
talk about it in a way that
like helps us grow towards something
positive yet I haven't I haven't found
that thing
um I think it's something that I'll
probably end up talking about if I feel
like I have to and it will be hard
because I do think there's a lot of
responsibility in a topic like that more
than than others artificial intelligence
is going to ruin our lives or uh make us
all superhumans
um
I think it's a I think there's a lot to
unpack there and I don't want to we're
like we've been going for a while so I
don't know how deep you want to go down
the rabbit we got nine minutes you can
talk about whatever you want I think at
the ground floor it's just like AI is
going to make everything look a lot
different I think that like I think that
the future that I most see coming is
like a weird future that we kind of
already uh what I'm writing about right
now
are facial reconstruction sort of
filters like things that you can you can
go online and make yourself look like
your teenage self or something like that
or you know deep fix uh uh something
that pirate wires has written a lot
about are are like the new um you want
to call them like sex fakes or deep fake
like porn things like this where people
are taking other people's
image and creating realistic looking
pornography featuring them against their
obviously without their consent and
that's like and they're doing that to
release it and like embarrass them or
they're doing it because they want to
see it that's and and they release it
online there were people who uh there's
a huge Scandal among a bunch of um
twitch streamers where one of the people
like a guy actually produced or he went
and looked at this it was like it was
like deep fake porn of someone who he
had he had actually collaborated with in
the past it was like a whole Scandal
um but that's just like a really weird
thing that we're gonna have to kind of
like think through uh there are also
other weird things that are really great
like
um one thing I often think about is like
I mean I really love Buffy the Vampire
Slayer growing up and we're approaching
a world where you could potentially have
like unlimited Buffy the Vampire slay
like you could be just like generating
Buffy the Vampire Slayer like season 455
personally tailored to you like you're
gonna be creative in terms of
entertainment it's like the the world is
your oyster in terms of maybe like
creating some version of yourself for
your kids and your great grandkids to
look at online like you can create like
a digital
a digital version of yourself that knows
that it's a maybe like an AI model
trained on everything you've ever
written
um that can then speak to your you know
your your progeny that's kind of cool uh
I don't know what it's going to do for
job loss no one ever does this is the I
don't like making predictions like this
because
I like kind of assessing the landscape
and being like here's what I think is
happening right now but when it comes to
what's happening five years from now in
a world of AI which is a paradigm
altering technology
um that is like we're dealing with an
intelligence now capable of of creating
art writing sonnets like already can
write music
um can replace most legal I don't know
I'm working with lawyers right now I'm
like there's 99 of what they've done and
it costs a lot
an AI I think can already do so it's
like that's going to change Everything's
Gonna Change I think that's the kind of
thing that's like well that's a huge
change for the better in a lot of
regards like all of us would love you
know a really expensive lawyer for the
cost of
a soda or something but what happens to
all the lawyers and what happens to not
just them right this is not like oh we
have a car and now the carriage drivers
are out of work it's like we have
something that thinks and so now
everybody who thinks for a living is out
of work potentially that's the negative
case uh the dream is that it just
amplifies everything right so now pirate
wires it's like me plus a hundred of my
clones that are you know reporting on
everything and that seems both
terrifying if you hate me and great if
you're me
uh have you guys started to use any of
the AI tools uh in either finding ideas
writing about ideas researching like
anything in actual I'm writing about
them right now uh I think I mean so the
most powerful chat we bot we've seen so
far uh was Sydney and that's definitely
been neutered at this point it was
Microsoft's Microsoft is using Chachi BT
um the latest version that no one else
even had uh to do it was it was uh this
chatbot that kind of revealed its name
which was Sydney and that was like a
whole other thing but that's that's
neutered right now and uh
um no I haven't been using it I can't
remember if it was you or somebody else
um you know was experimenting with chat
GPT and was asking it questions uh and
of course you ask a funny question and
then all sudden it very quickly becomes
like hey what do you think about Joe
Biden or hey what do you think about
Donald Trump and uh these chat Bots are
answering very differently depending on
political parties or candidates there's
other topics where it seems like they're
very uh verbose and willing to talk
about uh through the the uh AI bot and
then others that they completely avoid
and will literally say like hey I can't
talk about this or something
how important is it for us to get that
stuff right now versus it'll be an
iterative process in 20 years from now
we'll be on stage somewhere talking
about man the AI you know got this right
and got this wrong and it's just kind of
this long-term problem
I mean people are definitely
I've been in tech for
I think
11 years and
it's much more critical now than it was
back then
um
people are criticizing this stuff people
are from both sides they're you have
people who mostly on the left let's just
call spade a spade uh who like really
want more censorship on this thing and
the right-wing conversation is very much
like how do we keep political censorship
off of these AIS
um I don't even know how much is
happening to be honest I don't know how
much of it is political censorship right
now I I think that a lot of what's
happening I mean there there's certainly
quite a bit of it that we we know for
sure is happening but I think a lot of
what's Happening certainly what happened
with Bing uh Microsoft's
most recent chat was um the thing is
it's Googling itself to us it's using
Bing but no one uses Bing uh so it's
binging itself it's searching itself and
it's kind of telling you what other
people
um are saying about
yeah or to you it's telling you what you
want to hear and things like this it's
very good it's just a conversational
program
um
I think we're asking the right questions
I think we keep asking the right
questions it is potentially very
dangerous if uh AI is totally
centralized and all these other AI
companies are you know working off of
one and that one mainstream some kind of
really nefarious political censorship
some element of censorship is impossible
to avoid because we're all
eventually
these companies they have to call shots
uh on things like safety even something
like you know you don't want
um you don't want child porn on social
media and I don't that's a that's a shot
that's a value call right that is
censorship it's just a good censorship
so I'm like glad that exists but someone
called that shot and so there are lots
of shots like that that someone has to
call and those always come down to
biases where we get in trouble are the
ones that are more ambiguous like
um should you be allowed to talk about
the potential pitfalls of a vaccine on
very little information in the middle of
a pandemic and clearly people disagreed
on that one uh the problem was that you
had a few people who were in charge of
calling that shot and they called it in
a different direction
um I think that that's almost it's like
unavoidable with AI uh but people after
the Social Media stuff I think there's
hope for us to push back in a strong way
and at least get some semblance of uh of
openness is there a technology that
you're paying attention to that we
should be more worried about are more
excited about than maybe people are like
AI I think is now being pretty well
covered people may disagree on what the
outcomes are but uh if I go to a
mainstream website people will at least
be talking about chat gbt releases
something or Microsoft invest or
whatever
Bitcoin cryptocurrencies I think the
same thing maybe even there's some
biotech stuff now that's like become a
little bit more mainstream conversation
people are paying attention kind of
what's next or like what are other areas
that you think people should be paying
attention to that may be in the
mainstream media you know five years
from now I mean
AI was something that I was like
very exciting I think 10 years ago there
was a moment and you saw like deep mine
sold to Google and there was a lot of
progress made and
and then it kind of fell off it went
quiet for a while I think I got caught
up in the uh self-driving car
conversation and like the different
things that AI can do and and that
didn't come fast enough and then people
got sort of I think disenchanted by the
next one was like maybe VR which worked
but we had to invent a use case for I
think the average person certainly we
learned by the time of covid doesn't
want to live in their house they want to
connect with other human beings
um the the thing that I was most
exciting about excited about up until
maybe covid and then I was distracted by
the like collapsing clown world all
around us would have been bio stuff it
was like all the crispr stuff the
genetic engineering which is still
exciting but I guess it was a very long
way of answering your question which is
like the AI is just it that's it's like
it that's what is it's really the reason
that people are talking about it is
because it's really important it's it is
like very very new uh the advances that
we're now able to play with and use are
clearly very powerful and
um you can imagine all sorts of not even
imagine there are used cases coming out
right the use case of just someone using
it to draft an essay or an email that's
a use case that's something like VR
never had VR was a video game so that's
a use case it's fun but that's not we
already have there's you there's really
utility that's that we're already seeing
in AI
um that's the reason that people are are
I think so excited about it and then
there's like
it has its own mythology there's like
you have the AGI artificial general
intelligence the people talking about
that and what that looks like what does
it look like when a a computer not only
thinks but but wants things like we do
is that possible
um
is that in-game well I mean a lot of
people believe that's doomsday there are
people who believe that's like God and
that's like you know Utopia at that
point that's the singularity that's
there's a kind of a negative Singularity
or a positive Singularity and people
break off in both directions but
at its most basic it's just like this is
something that will change the way that
all of us work and there's no way to get
around that and so it sucked the air out
of almost everything else in Tech
um in a different I mean with crypto
that happened I think because people
were making so much money and with uh
and there were lots of cool things about
it always and there still are but the
reason that there was so much excitement
was because people were making money
with AI
um it's that's not the case how much of
AI now is like I'll call it the tech
phase versus the like interface phase
and I think we saw this with Bitcoin in
the first maybe 10 years or so of its
life and not until maybe 2020 2021 do we
really start to see it kind of start to
hit mainstream adoption and people say
hey I'm gonna go and I'm gonna buy it
there was a financial use case and
speculation was definitely a big piece
of that
um there's a hell of a lot of work that
was done for 10 years right kind of
behind the scenes or quietly you know in
the corners of Silicon Valley or
wherever
AI right now feels like there's a lot of
people trying a lot of different things
we've seen y combinator like a very
large portion of the companies they're
going through now or AI companies
but have we seen like the really big
breakout use case for people like oh
that's not a toy that's not a tool like
I mean you already have a use case in
generating art like what is the point of
ever hiring an artist for a piece of
work again like what is the point of of
hiring assistant to draft your emails
what is the point of
um I mean if you want a comprehensive uh
itinerary for your travel plan like you
just go and you use this thing and those
are things that we're using we're like
we're using it directly with a chat bot
like there are companies that are
building on top of this specifically to
do things like this there will be there
will be legal versions of this like
coming imminently you mentioned that uh
people have been working on this stuff
quietly for a lot of years that's true
the reason that people weren't excited
about it was because the people who were
doing it were doing it quietly working
in these different Labs or uh working at
Google and and whatnot and um they just
released it though once openai was gpt2
actually this was a couple years ago
that that one came out that was the
first time that everyone looked around
they were like whoa this is really
way more advanced than we thought it was
uh and then over the summer when the art
stuff came out it was like holy [__] we
are definitely there that was like a
gunshot start to the race
um you've seen every company in Silicon
Valley are in Tech
sort of every huge company come out and
be like oh yeah we've got an AI too and
a lot of them do or some of them do some
of them don't the fact that they feel
like they have to say that is maybe you
know that's that's hype but where I look
when you look abroad and you see all the
Chinese companies doing it now as well
that feels much more desperate like
there's an understanding
the CCP understands that they cannot
lose an AI arms race it will completely
dwarf there it will completely dwarf
them in terms of technology and so for
that reason alone to answer your
question on time Horizons like I think
it's all going to happen a lot more
quickly than
then
you would have thought given the last 10
years of relative silence because it's
like it's it wasn't just silence like it
wasn't nothing was happening things were
happening now we see it and now there's
a lot of pressure to be the person who
controls it I mean Google's come out
they're serious about it like there's
open AIS dominating like what's going to
happen in China that's not going to go
away that's going to be that's going to
be the the that's going to be the next
few years that will be the whole story I
think
while all of you pull out your phones
and subscribe to Pirate wires explain
what pirate wires is power wires is my
media company it's like kind of what I
was describing earlier it's like we're
out there on the landscape kind of
surveying what's happening uh it's like
me and uh the writers that I've hired my
editors
um and we just are kind of while having
a lot of fun uh making sense of the
world
um such as piratewireless.com uh we do
like uh we do a weekly a Weekly
Newsletter I do essays once every two
weeks we publish like sort of bang your
guest posts and stuff for my writer like
every week
my favorite thing is when I see the uh
the subject line of the email come out
I'm like oh boy let me sit down for this
one I'm like all right all right ladies
and gentlemen Mike Solana thank you guys